we are here with michael kolarkowski the
spokesperson of the granchester michael
welcome back to the show now tell us
your first impressions about poland and
how the tournament went from your
perspective well poland all together is
great country and warsaw is a capital
beautiful weather beautiful venue and
excellent tournament
especially with the veteran vishwanath
showing young players
what what it is to play
a real cheers when you're over 50. so we
will see whether he will be able to stay
on his course and win all together but
we we understand
that uh fabiana livon
and richard obviously want
to
to recapture
this lead as well as
home uh
trophy
duda who wants to
show that he is the real contender for
the first place not to mention that all
of the above players
uh
except anand are going to play one month
from now at the candidates tournament so
it's certainly sort of a showcase for
them
uh before the tournament and i believe
this is the last tournament that they
played together before candidates
tournament for the world championship
cycle definitely a beautiful preview of
those upcoming matches now talk to us a
bit about this incredible partnership
between the granchester the saint louis
just club and the super beth foundation
well i would say that it's perfect match
between two non-profit organizations
saint louis chess club and superbed
foundation
that basically put synergy
and mission to promote shias worldwide
and not only among elite players but
among youngsters as well and as you
could see
besides uh
this tournament in
i mean grancha's tour tournament uh
classical tournament in bucharest rapid
and blitz and warsaw we conducted
several side events and it brought so
many youngsters
and attention to
tournament
not only chess players but mainstream
and mainstream media
another big event is coming after this
one in croatia next month tell us a bit
about that what are you expecting to see
in that tournament
actually it would be very interesting
tournament because it
it would take place
upon conclusion of the candidates
tournament so we will know
who actually is going to be a challenger
for the world championship
cycle for the world championship title
and
breaking news
that world champion
reigning champion magnus carlsen is
going to participate in zagreb as a wild
card excellent and you told me that
there might be even more uh breaking
news is that correct and what can you
tell us about that yes in addition to
that magnus carlsen will participate
at the last stage of the grand chess
tour and classical event sinful cup so
it would be probably not probably
definitely the strongest tournament of
this year michael this is amazing news
thank you very much for breaking it for
all of us here in the studio thank you
very much and we'll see you in croatia
definitely you heard it here first
magnus carson will be playing both in
croatia and at the sink field cup in st
louis